oi bom dia
hoje eu vim aqui hoje compartilhar com
vocês o segredo da felicidade
o que é
a beleza sucesso riqueza
se alguém acredita nisso
ah pois é eu acreditava por incrível que
pareça eu fiz de tudo para perceber isso
e eu era o esteriótipo perfeito da
mulher feliz empresária bem-sucedida e
achava toda a europa casamento
aparentemente perfeito cílios
maravilhosos roupas de grife tudo como
manda o figurino só tinha um detalha um
pequeno detalhe eu era infeliz e
e eu tinha momentos assim de alegria
quando eu ganhar uma conta quando eu
viajava quando eu tinha alguma conquista
mas logo depois vi um vazio gigantesco
que ele vazio tomava conta de mim junto
com vasilha ouvir uma culpa como assim
essa mulher tem tudo para ser feliz como
é que ela pode sentir feliz por um
instante
e eu tinha que manter a pose de mulher
bem sucedida de mulher feliz
é mas a verdade é que eu não consegui
segurar essa pose ou muito tempo
só no dia dezenove de julho de 2016 toda
área externa do meu condomínio desmorono
ou
e eu cortei de madrugada junto com a
minha família
eu olhei para baixo 24 andares olhei
para baixo e vi tudo destruído
é mas descemos 24 andares no escuro no
meio de gritos de pavor de todos os
moradores todo mundo achando que ia
morrer e naquela noite eu achei que eu
perderia toda minha família
eu fui cena de terror dizem que quando a
gente está numa situação como essa que
os psicólogos chamam de quase morte é um
momento que a gente tem oportunidade de
rever toda a nossa vida naquele momento
eu entendi o quanto eu estava infeliz e
ao mesmo tempo eu percebi a urgência de
resolver isso eu ia morrer aos quarenta
anos quarenta anos infeliz não e naquele
momento eu decidi estudar sobre
felicidade
olá eu sou publicitária e eu sempre quis
mudar o mundo pela publicidade eu tentei
de todas as formas fazer isso eu queria
transformar
é só que eu esqueci de um pequeno
detalhe que essa transformação deveria
começar por mim mesma
e eu aprendi essa lição no meio da dor
bom e o que eu vou compartilhar com
vocês aqui hoje foi tudo que eu aprendi
os meus ensinamentos tiveram como base a
psicologia positiva a neurociência a
filosofia da yoga e o budismo porque eu
precisei e unir ciência e
espiritualidade para conseguir
sobreviver nesses últimos três anos e o
que que a felicidade me ensinou
felicidade me ensinou que ser feliz não
é luxo não é sutil não é opcional
a felicidade é uma ciência
a felicidade é uma matéria que ensinava
em universidades como harvard e ele
felicidade é assunto é tema de fórum
econômico mundial é assunto para
reuniões da onu a gente acha que
felicidade é coisa só de filósofos e de
poetas não felicidade é real e por que a
gente tem visto tanto interesse sobre o
tema felicidade
é porque apesar de toda evolução da
humanidade nós nunca estivemos tão
infelizes
é e quais são as razões diversas aumento
da desigualdade social aumento da
tecnologia aí o que desde os nossos
tempos como disse bauma mas eu vou me
até um ponto bem específico ao
desconhecimento do que é ser feliz
e nós não sabemos o que é mas ainda
confundimos felicidade com consumo com
sucesso um prazer o riqueza eu confundi
mas achamos que felicidade é uma algo
externo alguma coisa que acontece com a
gente como se felicidade fosse sorte
sinônimo de sorte mas também achamos que
felicidade é a satisfação instantânea
dos nossos desejos
é só tem um porém
os nossos desejos são intermináveis
e quanto mais a gente tem mas a gente
quer não é assim que funciona
e nós nos acostumamos ao que nós temos a
isso nós chamamos de adaptação hedônica
a gente acostuma facilmente a tudo que a
gente quer e com isso a nossa
infelicidade reina absoluta
e mais a boa notícia é que cientistas do
mundo inteiro estão coletando dados
analisando comportamentos e concluindo
algo muito importante felicidade é uma
habilidade que pode ser aprendida olha
que notícia maravilhosa
e se nós queremos ser mais felizes mas
precisamos rever todas as nossas
atitudes diante da vida quando falam
para gente que a nossa felicidade vem de
dentro sim pode acreditar mais
especificamente para que a felicidade
está aqui no nosso cérebro
e quando algo de bom ou ruim acontece
com a gente não é o fato em si que é bom
ou ruim mas sim como o nosso cérebro
processa os pensamentos
e tem um professor de raiva te chamar
acho que ele diz que somente 10 por
cento da nossa felicidade é previsto
pelo que acontece com a gente os outros
noventa porcento são previstos pela
forma como nosso cérebro processa esses
acontecimentos então porque é difícil o
que que o nosso cérebro maior parte do
tempo só traz pensamentos negativos
é porque o nosso cérebro ele não foi
programado para felicidade ele foi
programado para sobrevivência
e um atrás lá nos tempos das cavernas a
gente que precisava tal tempo inteiro
atento para evitar os perigos então se
eu visto um tigre eu tinha que sair
correndo desse tigre eu tinha que fugir
asfalto milhares de anos nosso cérebro
continua buscando tigres ficamos o tempo
inteiro atentos ao que é ruim o que é
negativo como uma ferramenta de
sobrevivência
e ao mesmo tempo o nosso cérebro que o
nosso cérebro tem muita facilidade em
perceber em guardar o que é negativo
nosso cérebro tem muita dificuldade de
guardar e de perceber o que é positivo
e a verdade é que o nosso cérebro ajudou
muito na evolução e na sobrevivência nos
trouxe até aqui mas prejudicou muito a
nossa felicidade
oi e aí é que a gente faz senta chora
ela na cérebro assim eu nunca mais vou
ser feliz não a ótima notícia é que você
não é o seu cérebro
o seu cérebro é um órgão comandado por
você mas especificamente pela sua mente
e o pai neurociência descobriu é que a
nossa mente os nossos pensamentos podem
mudar o nosso cérebro o que nós sentimos
e que nós pensamos aos poucos vai
esculpindo a estrutura neural
é mas aí a pergunta de um milhão de
dólares como fazer
o primeiro ponto é ter a consciência que
é você tem comanda a sua mente e não o
oposto tem um guru yogui bhajan
maravilhoso que ele dizia que a sua
mente pode ser sua maior amiga ou sua
pior inimiga
os grandes mestres como o buda por
exemplo de a mesma estrutura física que
todos nós temos mas eles conseguiram
mudar a sua o seu cérebro através da
mente a ponta de transformar o mundo a
grande chave o grande ponto é entender
que o cérebro
o positivo gera emoções positivas e
quanto maior o número de emoções
positivas maior a nossa sensação de
felicidade
e eu vou compartilhar com vocês três
práticas simples e fáceis de fazer e que
podem contribuir muito momento de
percepção de felicidade a primeira
prática é a gratidão
a praticar gratidão pode parecer um
daqueles conselhos melosos de livros de
auto-ajuda mas o que a ciência vem
mostrando são assim benefícios absurdos
onde a gente pratica gratidão quando a
gente começa a observar coisas que são
positivas com a gente a gente muda a
forma como nosso cérebro trabalha ao
invés de olhar o negativo ele passa a
olhar o positivo e quando a gente fala
de gratidão a gente não tá falando de
oração nós chegar na final do dia e
falar muito obrigada por tudo que
aconteceu a orientação é você escrever
diariamente de três a cinco coisas que
você é grato
e como é que sair para funciona a partir
daí ele vai passar o dia e se caminhando
e buscando tudo o que é positivo
e parece milagre mas é neurociência
o segundo ponto meditação
e a meditação nada mais é do que viver a
vida e moto presente e só existe um
momento um lugar para ser feliz aqui e
agora cinquenta por cento do nosso tempo
nosso cérebro em outro lugar e um
cérebro em outro lugar não é um cérebro
feliz a meditação libera serotonina
dopamina endorfina são todos os
hormônios que são considerados hormônios
da felicidade ajuda reduzir o cortisol
que o hormônio do stress muita gente tem
dificuldade com meditação que pensa não
eu não consigo ficar sem pensar imagina
realmente se eu ficar sem pensar
significa que você tá morto
e quando você estiver vivo seus
pensamentos existiram você não pode se
apegar aos seus pensamentos existem
diversos tipos de meditação vale a pena
tentar a felicidade agradece terceiro
ponto pratica atos de gentileza
e os estudos mostram as pessoas mais
felizes são pessoas mais altruístas
pessoas que praticam bem praticar o bem
ativa o mesmo centro de prazer no
cérebro que ativada por comida e sexo só
de pensar em fazer o bem você já se
sente mais feliz e um círculo virtuoso
quanto mais bem você pratica mas feliz
você fica e mais bem você quer praticar
e cá entre nós o mundo precisa
desesperadamente de pessoas que façam
bem nem que seja para ser mais feliz
é tão que nós vimos até agora que nós
somos 100% responsáveis pela nossa
felicidade
e nós podemos controlar a nossa mente
porque uma mente saudável positiva gera
emoções positivas nós para a gente
conseguir transformar a gente precisa
primeiro transformar-se próprio então
nós podemos adotar hábitos diários que
ajudam aumentar nossa percepção de
felicidade
olá tudo está sob nosso controle
é mas essas coisas que a gente não
controla
bom e foi aí que eu tive a maior
decepção da minha vida
no sábado 30 de março de 2019
oi eu tava no café numa reunião e eu
recebo a ligação do meu filho caio e ele
me disse
oi mãe eu levei um tiro eu vou morrer
e tu tem um filho consegue imaginar o
que eu vi isso
um momento como esse o corpo treme a
visão fica turva a boca seca
e eu estava aproximadamente 20 minutos
de distância de onde meu filho havia
sido baleada
e nessas 20 minutos só precisa ser
manter meus pensamentos sobre controle
eu simplesmente não surtasse
e por 20 minutos mais longos da minha
vida naquele momento eu entendi o
significado da fé
e eu só pensava se eu pedia para que meu
filho estivesse vivo
oi albert einstein dizia que existem
duas formas de viver a vida uma como se
nada fosse um milagre e a outra é como
se tudo fosse cheguei meu filho estava
vivo
e eu tive tempo de me ajoelhar no chão e
pedir a deus falar agradecer com tanta
intensidade que o médico precisou dizer
o mãe você vai ficar aí ajoelhado ou
você vai com seu filho na ambulância eu
levantei e fomos para o hospital
tá chegando lá o diagnóstico meu filho
ficaria paralisado da cintura para baixo
oi e a chance dele voltar andar ainda
são incertas e
é mas contrariando o que a maiorias
poderia sentir num momento como esse eu
não sente raiva ou revolta
é sem dúvida vive o momento mais difícil
da minha vida uma tristeza profunda
é mas eu tive que acolher aquela dor eu
tive que aceitar o que aconteceu e mesmo
diante de vários sentimentos misturados
tristeza frustração ao mesmo tempo
alegria fé e esperança do meu filho um
dia voltar a andar
e eu pude entender daquilo como um
milagre
e infelizmente a gente não pode
controlar a dor a perda a violência
é mas a gente pode controlar a forma
como a gente reagir diante dos fatos e é
nesse controle que está todo nosso poder
bom e foi exatamente isso que aconteceu
comigo eu não pude controlar a violência
contra o meu filho mas eu pude controlar
a forma como reage a ela
e a praticar gratidão nesses 3 anos
é a única coisa que me veio à mente
oi meu filho está vivo e isso eu
agradeço todos os dias
e depois de tudo que aconteceu comigo eu
adotei como missão
e compartilhar o que eu aprendi sobre a
felicidade a que mais pessoas consigam
enxergar a vida pelas lentes da
felicidade a gente possa escanear o
nosso mundo não pelo negativo mas pelo
positivo
e aí para tu aí no meu braço mantra se
chama louca samastah sukhino bhavantu
mais do que uma tradução uma orientação
para vida que eu quero ter
o que todos os seres sejam felizes e que
todos os meus pensamentos meus atos e
minhas palavras contribui para a
felicidade de todos os seres
e às vezes a gente pensa eu te espera
uma vida perfeita para ser feliz e eu
posso dizer para vocês que essa vida não
existe não espere uma vida perfeita isso
não vai acontecer
e muitas vezes nós achamos que sucesso
que consumo isso que vai trazer a
felicidade eu digo para vocês que não
e se a tristeza chegar
e a colha
é a grande questão não é o sentimento em
si
é do que você faz com ele
e se não fosse por um momento muito
triste lá atrás eu não teria de estudar
felicidade eu não estaria aqui diante de
vocês mas eu decidi pegar algo muito
ruim mas é grande tristeza e transformar
em algo positivo e construtivo
e vocês podem falar assim não flávia
isso para você fácil você é forte não eu
não há se forte eu me fiz forte
e eu não tive uma vida feliz eu aprendi
a ser feliz é
e eu digo que hoje sem esse aprendizado
eu não teria conseguido suportar tudo
que eu vivi até aqui hoje eu digo para
vocês que a felicidade me salvou
obrigada tchau
e aí